welcome to this video playing smooth
snubber or whatever
hmm I wonder what this means all right
this is a German feed Amasa actually
know him he played a couple of years ago
um for club of my own current residence
here in that this book but he moved to
release and part of Germany not quite
sure
Erfurt online seeker something is it in
there no yeah whatever it's it's the
London system not exactly
guaranteeing very exciting games but
nevertheless let's let's try night 94
yeah
whatever he's doing he's doing it
quickly Oh taking with the porn it's so
surprising why am I going to de 7
why not C 6 C 6 85
yeah this would have been I would have
been much better really
okay
yeah okay cannot take here okay so we
will probably drop the Queen back to a
three no he won't
yeah don't know can never take on a
seven
yeah 96 was much better than 97 but
nothing to do about that now
okay so d5 I always have there should be
seven with the tempo so d5 is not not a
problem and my ideas play e5 here they
could have done that actually I'm
playing too quickly him he five I was
was interesting because of the hanging
bishop
so now D 5 D for emphasis idea and then
this night okay let's cover that D 5
then this is interesting and taking only
form this is also risky for me because
the pawn might get lost
yeah but he's very quick and going for
that my idea was that yeah it's a lie
it's really cool they they play those
super committal moves always instantly
like this is so idiotically you could
play it instantly I mean okay I saw that
actually and thought okay maybe I have
some fun to play here his queen is
offside and so on but just instantly it
is played I don't I don't understand why
it could have easily waited with
capturing and the lady for this was was
interesting and now he's starting to
think so
Bishop f5 him and rook f6 g6 if the
knight moves or just take g6 this is a
good compensation for black anyway
check came so Queen d7 one other let's
let's and get the rook involved his
queen is on a three being somewhat lazy
spectator
okay Bishop iam in attending group chief
form yeah it is ignored or g6 both when
they exchanged
if for efore intending look f3 the most
aggressive at least twin takes our take
f2 I'm threatening rook f3 now
keeping the rookie eject so we are now I
can play III I think not
hmm should I be able to play you three
now chicks
hmm doesn't seem to work
curiously enough
okay then just scrap this
probably not so bad as well so hmm
justtake here right and promoting white
resigns yeah I'm sorry about those
outbursts sometimes because I simply
don't get it this this playing the super
committal moves instantly like here one
second and I guess this is just bad I
mean he's just weakens his King side the
Queen is offside and he needs to do
something else he can easily prepare all
this I'm not saying that I'm great here
no way it's not clear but just playing
you really need to invest a bit of time
for those super committal moves and this
thing is just bad yeah the computer
gives us us winning already for black
very quickly because I get I get the
pieces over quickly on the on the
kingside and the screen is off side and
those pieces all bad if you don't take
let's say I don't play g4 then it's it's
not clear we can maybe get the Queen
back and prepare this of course I can
play h5 and stuff but those bishops are
looking at pawns at the moment so it's
not so dramatic and this just opens up
your own King and you saw how quickly
this is turned into into a nightmare
Queen d7 was even better here yeah but
the way it was it was played Jack was
also terrible for white yeah okay I'm
guilty of thinking too long sometimes
but playing so committal move like g4
and one second is really bad and he is a
good player I mean if he takes some
seconds he will see that this is not
good but playing it instantly as some is
just handing over the game here to black
thanks for watching